Yeah,
that's a good thing.
It's mostly bullshit it,
well,
you had Tyson on.
Yeah,
and it was interesting that he didn't want to go back to it.
Do you know Marvin Hagler has the same problem?
Oh yeah.
Well he was the only guy that ever just quit at the top,
but he won't,
he won't punch a bag or anything because that thing comes up in him where he
wants to do it again.
It's like an addiction and he's gotta be 60 now.
It's still,
yeah,
still welling up inside of him.
I respect him so much.
You know,
I always looked up to him when I was fighting cause a,
I remember the discipline that doc I had,
like I remember watching videos of him,
but he was a living on the cape.
He would treat you as Trump and he would run and the boots with combat boots on.
Yeah,
he was,
he was yelling war.
He was like getting ready to fight my staff at Hampshire and he's running and
shadow boxing is Yellen war.
And I'm like,
I'm just thinking,
could you imagine if you had a fight?
That fucking guy,
when he was the middle weight champion of the world,
first of all,
he was chiseled like it was sculpted out of bronze.
They didn't even look like,
I mean,
he was,
he was so jacked for a boxer.
When you think about like most boxers,
they didn't have that kind of physique.
His physique was like almost like a gymnast,
you know,
when he was in his prime and he just was so disciplined in Sofa and then beat
the fuck out of everybody and then lost that one.
Very controversial fight to sugar in matter.
I was at the point.
Yeah.
And then he was like,
that's it.
See Ya.
I've had enough.
Went to Italy.
He became a fucking movie star,
which is crazy.
He said,
apparently,
I mean,
I've never seen an Italian movie with Ma Marvelous Marvin Hagler in it.
Nobody has.
I think they,
I think Natalie,
I think it's a myth,
if he might be a myth.
[inaudible]
Ross was the rumor was always that he threw the fight with Leonard that he could
CalEd Leonard.
But he did,
if you all had to do is let,
let it go to a decision,
he would lose that decision.
They pay him a boatload of cash and he goes to Italy.
What does it says?
Marvin Hagler and a movie.
I just don't really,
oh,
he is in a movie.
I'm not saying that Jesus Christ.
Oh,
that's a long time ago because he looks really young back.
Oh my God.
He isn't.
Why no one's ever seen those movies.
Wow.
So this is an Italian,
well,
you know,
they made all those spaghetti westerns with [inaudible].
They did all those movies in Italy.
Oh my God.
Isn't that something?
Those movies,
those a job look at you look at,
he's shooting everybody.
Oh yeah.
Is an access.
That's hilarious.
I wonder while he's still jacked in that movie,
so he must've been doing some kind of exercising.
What good them.
Oh God.
He's funny.
Jesus Christ flying through the air.
So India,
it looks like,
oh,
this is so hilarious.
This is so hilarious.
So,
you know,
when you do a movie and the guy hits you,
you're supposed to move your head so that he's not actually hitting you.
And I hope Marvin knew that.
I'm sure he had because he,
yeah,
thank God I pulled the punch,
I did a movie in,
um,
Boston called southy with a guy,
throws me in a dumpster and kills me.
Right.
And they had to do it over and over.
And the guy just got out of Walpole,
the state penitentiary.
Um,
I'm not gonna mention his name,
but he's,
he's the director now out here as a matter of fact.
And I said,
Hey,
do you know this is a fucking movie?
Because the fire in the fight,
you know the shot that the starter's pistol and he kept throwing me over.
That guy is in everything.
Brian.
Brian Dennehy was 1989 90 oh one.
So 89 was probably just a few years after he retired.
He retired somewhere around 86 87.
When did he fight Leonard?
What are never that was,
oh,
it was amazing.
We used to watch [inaudible] closed circuit fights.
We'd go to a theater and watch it on a big screen closer.
Tell you how many I got so ripped off because you had ties to Iran.
I remember driving,
I was out here to go to this big fight,
50 bucks,
and I'd walked in and Tyson knock them out in the first round.
That was all,
that never happened.
People were trying to figure out what he was amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it was a,
it's,
what did we say?
Seven,
eight,
seven.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Yeah,
and that was it.
He's like,
I'm done.
So that was only two years after he retired.
He's doing movies,
but the best John the beast Mugabi but Marvin haggler versus John the beast mode
gun.
Marvin have hair from a Gabi.
No,
I remember seeing Martin with hair at the gardens.
What?
Yeah.
Did he grow it out for a goof?
No,
he had a,
Harley has created a really fucking heart.
He had an extra inch of scholar or something.
They was saying,
no,
the side temples,
is that what it was?
Temple muscles.
They said he was almost like built.
Is that Mugabe and Mugabe was a murderous,
no,
that's Thomas Hearns voice.
Thomas Thomas.
That's Mugabi for sure.
Mugabi he hit Marvin Hagler with an upper cut and snapped his head back and this
was an Africa that he was knocking everybody out.
But Non Marvin Marvin took a punch better than anybody.
He said the fight only started.
Why stock the pan?
I think one role,
Dan was the only guy that ever knocked Marvin down,
but it wasn't a real knockdown.
It was a trip and they counted it as a knockdown.
Oh,
he was a tremendous fighter.
But Oh,
inside.
Look at how it gets into the PSOAS.
Mugabe.
Mugabe was a murderer as punching him til he was knocking everybody out.
He knocked out Terry Norris.
He knocked,
he knocked people out dead like you would hit them and they would go flying,
but not Marvin Kreiss.
Marvin stood right in front of him and eventually Koom and then Mugabe was never
the same again.
Once he realized that this mother fucker could stand right in front of him,
the shit out shots.
What does this referee stop?
What is he doing?
I don't know what's going on.
Then that's mills lane and now that we have a break in the action,
I'd like to,
I'd like to plug my movies.
Sweeney killing Sweeney.
Yeah,
middle of March.
We talked about it.
It's coming out.
I want,
I want to plug it again.
Well,
toolkit plug and we'll plug the shit out of it when it comes out.
We'll put it on Twitter.
Right.
Fighting.
But I appreciate that.
But he was that guy.
Marvin Hagler was to me like he was the epitome of discipline,
you know,
and I thought about like a discipline fighter like that.
It was him always in shape,
always ready to go,
and then the discipline to never come back.
That was amazing too.
To me.
I've respected the fuck out of that because fighters never know when to when to
leave.
He knew when to leave.
And to this day I saw him in an interview recently.
He's fine.
Talks completely normal.